dans l'actualité donc les etats unis qui
mettent un nouveau coup de pression à la
russie pour le président joe biden le
risque d'une invasion de l'ukraine par
moscou est très élevé ce soir le chef de
la diplomatie américaine anthony blinken
a décrit devant l'onu le scénario d'une
attaque on en parle avec à notre
correspondant à washington thomas bonnin
bonsoir thomas devant le conseil de
sécurité des nations unies anthony
blinken a donc exhorté la russie à
abandonner la voie de la guerre
oui anthony blinken qui avait donc
décidé de se rendre en personne à cette
réunion du conseil de sécurité des
nations unies une étape dans son voyage
qui devait le conduire à munich on nous
dit qu'il ya eu de longues consultations
entre la maison blanche et le
département d'état américain pour
finalement parvenir à la décision que ce
soit anthony blinken a qui prennent la
parole il a donc pris la parole il y à
quelques heures maintenant il explique
que nous sommes face à un moment de
péril pour des millions de personnes il
réaffirme que les états unis ne peuvent
toujours pas vérifié le retrait d'une
partie des troupes russes le long de la
frontière ukrainienne au contraire les
autorités américaines explique que la
russie a renforcé ses capacités
militaires dans la région au cours des
derniers jours il a même donc donné
quelques détails sur ce à quoi pourrait
ressembler une offensive de la russie en
ukraine et il répond également à ceux
qui mettraient en doute les affirmations
des autorités américaines écouter
attaque interviendrait dans un deuxième
temps des missiles des bombes serait
largué en ukraine les communications sur
est brouillée des cyberattaques
réduire à néant les institutions
ukrainienne clé après ça des chars des
soldats russes avancerez visant des
cibles déjà identifié
cartographier de manière très détaillée
nous pensons que ces cibles sont
notamment la capitale de la le l'ukraine
kiev une ville de 2 8 millions de
personnes je sais que d'aucuns ont
remises en question les informations
communiquées par moi même rappelant que
par le passé des renseignements obtenus
s'était avéré erroné mais que les choses
soient claires je suis ici aujourd'hui
non pas pour lancer une guerre mais pour
en empêcher une
selon le chef de la diplomatie
américaine moscou doit désormais
démontrer sa volonté de désescalade en
renvoyant les troupes russes dans leurs
casernes alors il ya une réaction du
représentant russe lors de cette réunion
du conseil de sécurité à des nations
unies il regrette le fait que washington
fasse monter les tensions et que les
déclarations russes de ces derniers
jours ne soient pas entendus par les
pays occidentaux écoutez le
trouve cela dommage
qu'on n'ait pas entendu les affirmations
les déclarations très sérieuse de
monsieur poutine ces derniers jours sur
la situation en ukraine dans l'est de ce
pays alors je demanderai à nos
partenaires d'écouter ce qu'il a dit à
la conférence de presse
alors qu'à moscou
il y avait
le président de la france le chancelier
de l'allemagne
qui est à l'issue de ces pourparlers il
ya une conférence de presse et donc nos
invités et le président de la fédération
de russie se sont exprimés
parmi les autres prises de parole lors
de cette réunion du conseil de sécurité
des nations unies on a notamment pu
entendre le représentant britannique
formule est lui aussi ses inquiétudes
sur la situation le long de la frontière
ukrainienne ou encore le représentant
chinois qui estime que l'élargissement
de l'otan est une question que l'on ne
peut pas évacuer face aux tensions en
ukraine alors un peu plus tôt dans la
journée c'est le président américain joe
biden qui s'étaient exprimés face à des
journalistes il affirme à nouveau qu'une
attaque de la russie pourrait intervenir
dans les tout prochains jours écouté le
nous avons des raisons de croire qu'ils
sont engagés dans une opération prétexte
pour avoir une excuse pour y aller
toutes les indications que nous avons
c'est qu'ils sont prêts à rentrer en
ukraine attaque et l'ukraine
le président américain qui explique
aussi qu'il n'a pas prévu à ce stade de
s'entretenir par téléphone avec vladimir
poutine en tout cas au cours des
prochains jours en revanche anthony
blinken aurait proposé une réunion à son
homologue russe sergueï lavrov pour le
courant de la semaine prochaine enfin
washington prépare également sa réponse
suite à l'expulsion par moscou du numéro
deux de l'ambassade américaine en russie
un acte considéré par le département
d'état américain comme une étape
supplémentaire dans l' escalade
merci thomas bonnin en direct de
washington